Let's now explore an example of
a force in which the work done
it is not path independent.
And the classic example
is the friction force.
So let's consider
the following setup.
Suppose we have a horizontal
surface with friction
and we have an object.
And we're moving this object.
So let's choose an origin.
We'll call this plus
x, our i hat direction,
it's all going to be
one-dimensional motion.
And we're going to move
this object from an initial
to a final state.
And were going to
move it directly
in a straight line from the
initial to the final state.
And this will be our path 1.
And in our second
case, what we'd
like to contrast with
that, is that we'd
like to move the object
out to a point xa
and then back to
the final point.
So this is our path 2.
Has two legs.
And we'd like to compare the
work done on these two paths.
So for path 1 we'll begin by
calculating-- our force here
is the kinetic friction force.
And the kinetic friction force
remember is, in this case,
it's going to oppose the motion.
So we have force
kinetic for path 1,
and that is minus mu k mg
in the i-hat direction.
And so when we do the
integral for the work
from x initial to x
final, this is path 1,
then we have minus mu k
mg i-hat dotted into-- Now
what is the ds for this path?
It's simply dx
i-hat, so dx i-hat.
Notice we're not putting
any sign into dx.
The sign will show up
in terms of our end
points of our integral.
So we do the dot
product here, we
have i-hat dot i-hat, that's 1.
And so this interval, we can
pull out all the constants,
mu k mg.
We're just integrating dx
from x initial to x final.
And so we get mu k mg times
x final minus x initial.
Now for path 2 we have
two separate integrals.
So for path 2 we'll
just show the first part
where we're going
from x initial to xa.
Then the friction force
is opposing the motion.
And we always just write dx in
terms of the coordinate system,
dx i-hat because you'll see that
the signs show up in the end
points of the integral.
And then when
we're coming back--
I'll put that in a different
color and I'll put it below it.
So when we come back,
notice the friction force
is going to change direction.
ds will still be
written that way
but pay close attention to the
end points of the integral.
So now what we have
is two integrals.
So W is the integral
from x initial to xa.
And now I'm going to take the
dot products here directly.
It's the same friction
force, we still
have this same integral,
which is minus mu k mg dx.
Now here's where it's
a little bit tricky.
Notice on this path fk
is plus mu k mg i-hat.
And so when we dotted into
dx we have a plus sign,
we'll just continue
that integration here,
of mu k mg dx from
xa to x final.
Both of these integrals are
straightforward integrals
to do.
This is minus mu k mg
xa minus x initial.
And over here, we have a plus
mu k mg x final minus x initial.
Notice x final minus
xa, rather, is negative.
And so both of these integrals
are negative, as we expect.
And so what we see here is
that we have two pieces,
so minus 2 mu k mg xa.
And then we have that
other piece, mu k mg
x final minus x initial.
Hang on, this is
actually a plus sign.
So our answer is very
different because the
displaced the amount that
we've traveled is different.
So what we see here is an
example of a force which
is the work done is
not path independent
but depends on the path
taken from the initial
to the final states.